it's kind of crazy Jimmy Stewart takes
uh takes this kind of Dana's bit
beautiful blonde woman up and yeah up in
this Tower uh and then you know she
goes flying out of the Tower and so then
he comes back later on to the same
Mission with uh uh you know Kim Novak
with Kim Novak and I just do him running
into a nun and saying I'm just we're
gonna get one more try here
and there the nuns are like no no no no
no you were here once we're the blonde
who looks excited she died she died no
no no I know I know no no I know I know
I just shot you know
one more time I just would probably
think I'm some sort of a creep
and then I do him going after the second
the second one like I kind of landed in
the same spot